dans notre abondant courrier le problème
des assurances revient beaucoup plus
souvent qu'à son tour et dans les
automobilistes se plaignent en général
que l'on ne respecte pas le contrat et
les assureurs eux estiment que c'est le
code de la route qui n'est pas toujours
respectée dans le premier cas nous
essayons d'intervenir auprès des
assureurs vous voyez à cette émission
nous faisons assez souvent et pour ce
qui est du code de la route
eh bien nous avons soumis ce petit
lexique proposé par gérard tableau pour
éviter les accidents de la circulation
trawick appelle tous les chemins
vicinaux madame ans et bien c'est quand
on sait peut-être que c'est pour aller
quand on est allé aux toilettes faire un
brin de toilette avant de passer à table
et comment nourrissent pas dire
l'expression donc baisser on dit
vicinaux andy cette expression on a
commencé les sino les chemins vicinaux
somme investie nos voilà en direct et en
disto mollahs à la place pour vouloir
dire quoi pour vouloir dire vvc quoi w
ses empreintes auriez-vous volontiers
les grands axes madame les prêter oui à
quelqu'un que je connaîtrai mais
autrement emprunter non pourquoi je ne
sais pas c'est mon tempérament comme ça
j'aime mieux prêter que d'emprunter
voyez ce que c'est que le grand jacques
est ce que c'est la rn13 ça vous dit
quelque chose
oui c'est une reine dans son mari était
le 14 ou
louis xiii qui le qui gouverner un
peuple quel peuple un peuple un peuple
quel pays france comment faut-il s'y
prendre pour supprimer les points noirs
de la circulation
ben faut laisser faire la nature faut
laisser faire ça guérit tout seul
peut-être par mois voyez ce que je veux
dire quand je parle de points noirs de
la circulation
oui bah oui puisque c'est passé les
boutons circulation du sang on parle
beaucoup à certaines époques du pc de
ronnie qu'est ce que c'est que le pc de
ronnie monsieur ça c'était le siège du
parti communiste n'ont à peu près voilà
c'est un siège qui est un renouveau du
parti communiste et à roanne se voit que
pensez-vous les bretelles d'accès et
bien moi personnellement je préfère la
ceinture mais ça c'est chacun tout un
chacun moi je trouve que la ceinture est
plus rapide que les bretelles et
bretelles me direz ça peut aller au tout
aussi vite si vous faites un côté
l'autre sans faire attention
ce serait quand même aussi vite dégagé
mais enfin le reste elle reste avant le
résultat quoi la voie secondaire à votre
avis qu'est ce que s'est passé ce qui
est derrière le chanteur
par exemple passer ce qui qui fait les
choeurs derrière qui reprend la voix du
chanteur qui fait quoi qui fait la la la
la la la la la la voie sera la voie
secondaire
c'est ce que vous en pensez vous des
voies secondaires j'aime pas tellement
bas plutôt chanteur en lui même je pense
que c'est la voie principale et voilà la
voie principale gabelt ont le sens
province paris
ben c'est de paris il pense que les gens
de l'extérieur de paris qui sont qui
s'en fout et puis que la province ils
pensent que c'est pas et les gens de
paris il s'en fout parce qu'ils ont
chacun leur sens de leur sens leur sens
de leur sens et leur vous vous avez quoi
le sens province paris où le sens
paris-province le sens
romain ce pari c'est à dire c'est à dire
vous avez l'impression l'impression de
ne pas être comme ces de paris comment
ils sont sept paris va il s'en fout
voyez où est ce qu'on appelle rouler au
pas monsieur l'a roulé au pas c'est
marcher un peu comme comme ça enfin fait
moins rire
alors là vous roulez repas
un peu pourquoi ou le temps au banc
alors faire épater les filles pour fair
épater les filles ont besoin comment
elle en fait - world
voilà bah vous roulez drôlement bien on
pas merci monsieur et bravo mais qui
fait tout le monde et ben voilà c'est
terminé
c'était